und jetzt spricht sie sehen schon
christian lettner bundesfinanz
über internationale zusammenarbeit und
solidarität zu reden jetzt ist die zeit
die werte des grundgesetzes
freiheit und internationale solidarität
zu leben
russland hat einen völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine begonnen
das ist das ende aller hoffnung auf
frieden und es ist auch das ende aller
illusionen über putins russland in
dieser zeit der entscheidung ist
klarheit gefordert wo wir stehen wir
stehen in solidarität an der seite der
ukraine
was haben wir hier gerade gehört
was für ein bild der gründe warum es zu
diesen krieg gekommen ist
sagen wir es in aller klarheit
putin hat die ukraine angegriffen weil
sich ein souveräner staat
in freier selbstbestimmung
dafür entschieden hat seinen weg nach
westen zu gehen
die ukraine ist ein souveräner staat
und sie hatte von ihrem recht gebrauch
gemacht über ihre zukunft zu entscheiden
und sie hat sich gegen autoritative muss
entschieden sie hat sich für demokratie
und rechtsstaatlichkeit entschieden die
gäste angegriffen worden
der angriff auf die ukraine ist deshalb
nicht nur der überfall auf einen
souveränen staat es ist ein angriff auf
eine werteordnung es ist ein angriff auf
uns alle
wir waren und sind solidarisch mit der
ukraine gemeinsam mit unseren partnern
in der europäischen union und im kreise
der g 7 deutschland hat in der
vergangenheit erhebliche finanzielle
mittel bereitgestellt zur unterstützung
der ukraine und das werden wir
fortsetzen schon in dieser woche werden
wir im kreis der g 7 staaten beraten was
an zusätzlicher hilfe nötig ist wir sind
aber zugleich auch entschlossen
wir ziehen diejenigen mit den mitteln
des rechts zur rechenschaft
die verantwortung dafür tragen dass das
völkerrecht gebrochen wurde wir werden
russland isolieren
wirtschaftlich finanziell und politisch
wir treffen
wir treten russlands banken wir treffen
russlands oligarchen wir treffen
russlands wirtschaft diese aktionen wie
wir beschlossen haben diese sanktionen
sind auf dauer angelegt wir brauchen
einen langen atem
wir haben diesen langen atem
diese sanktionen werden negative
auswirkungen auch auf uns haben aber wir
sind bereit diese negativen auswirkungen
zu tragen denn sie sind der preis der
freiheit
die bundesregierung unternimmt alles um
maximalen druck auf putin auszuüben und
zugleich eine schwächung unserer
position zu begrenzen
erstens wir haben
sorgfältig unter federführung des
kanzleramts an finanziellen sanktionen
gearbeitet die putin keinen vorwand
biete
notwendige rohstofflieferungen
auszusetzen die auf der anderen seite
aber erreichen dass es mit russland
wortwörtlich kein business as usual mehr
geben wird
damit
und damit enden wir nicht die deutschen
und europäischen finanzbehörden wir
werden alles unternehmen um
geldströme und
vermögenswerte derjenigen die putin
unterstützen zu identifizieren und
einzufrieren
zweitens
wir werden reserven bei gas und kohle
aufbauen um unsere
durchhaltefähigkeit auszubauen dafür
haben wir mittel im milliardenbereich
eingeplant
drittens die bedeutung der
energiesicherheit
erfährt eine neue priorität
unsere planungen der nächsten jahre
werden wir an die veränderte lage
anpassen müssen dabei werden wir nicht
setzen auf die antworten der
vergangenheit sondern im gegenteil den
weg in die zukunft
entschlossener fortsetzen erneuerbare
energien läuft nämlich nicht nur einen
beitrag
zur energiesicherheit und versorgung
erneuerbare energien lösen uns von
abhängigkeiten erneuerbare energien sind
deshalb frei heizenergie
wir setzen auch frei heizenergie
viertens
die stabilität der öffentlichen finanzen
und die handlungsfähigkeit des staates
müssen erhalten bleiben
die schuldenbremse gilt
das vertrauen der internationalen
kapitalmärkte in deutschland begründet
eine unserer stärken
und fünftens die
anstrengungen die vor uns liegen sind
enorm die anstrengungen die vor uns
liegen erfordern wirtschaftliche stärke
und deshalb ist auch eine konsequenz aus
der veränderten geopolitische lage dass
wir unsere eigene wirtschaftliche
substanz stärken und alles unterlassen
was diese wirtschaftliche stärke
reduziert
die wir kolleginnen und kollegen
[Applaus]
wir haben viele jahre eine
friedensdividende genutzt
die bundeswehr wurde vernachlässigt
in diesen tagen wurde noch über eine
taxonomie gesprochen die investitionen
in
verteidigungsfähigkeit eingeschränkt
hätte
der krieg in der ukraine
weckt uns alle aus einem
selbstgerechten traum
die zeit der vernachlässigung der
bundeswehr muss enden
wir werden deshalb in der laufenden
finanzplanung und in jedem haushaltsjahr
die mittel für den verteidigungshaushalt
erhöhen
wir werden den laufenden betrieb der
bundeswehr
werden den laufenden betrieb der
bundeswehr aus den laufenden haushalten
unter achtung der schuldenbremse
finanzieren aber eine jahrelange
mindestens 15 jahre dauernde
vernachlässigung der bundeswehr
kann man nicht von jetzt auf gleich im
laufenden haushalt korrigieren und
deshalb
und deshalb müssen wir zu einem anderen
mittel greifen die bundeswehr tüchtigen
notwendiges material um notwendige
technik anzuschaffen werden wir der
bundeskanzler hat es gesagt ein
sondervermögen einrichten
100 milliarden euro wollen wir dafür zur
verfügung stellen wir wollen dieses
sondervermögen im grundgesetz absichern
um deutlich zu machen dass die
verwendung nur und ausschließlich für
die stärkung unserer bündnisfähigkeit
gedacht ist dafür brauchen wir die
unterstützung der länder dafür brauchen
wir die unterstützung der cdu csu
friedrich merz wir werden nicht danach
fragen
wer die verantwortung für den zustand
der bundeswehr hat wir werden nicht mit
dem finger aufeinander zu zeigen
aber wir erwarten dass beim blick in die
zukunft und bei der schaffung einer
bundeswehr die wieder ihren
bündnisverpflichtungen gerecht werden
kann die opposition die bundesregierung
unterstützt
ja
ja 100 milliarden euro neben den
jährlichen haushalten das ist eine
enorme summe geld sprechen wir es offen
aus am geld allein hat es nicht
gemangelt sollen wir werden auch über
die strukturen der bundeswehr sprechen
müssen über ihren auftrag
über die möglichkeit mit den mitteln
auch tatsächlich äußere sicherheit zu
garantieren
für diese debatte sind wir offen diese
debatte werden wir führen aber die
investitionen in die bundeswehr über
friedrich merz die sollten sie nicht
führen mit der warnung von neuen
schulden das sind in wahrheit natürlich
kredite die wir aufnehmen in den
nächsten jahr aber in dieser welt lage
sind es zunächst und zumeist
investitionen in unsere freiheit
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
was sind das für mutige menschen in der
ukraine die für ihre freiheit kämpfen
die in ihrem land
unsere westlichen werte leben wollen
[Musik]
sie nehmen uns auch in eine
verantwortung sie nehmen uns in die
verantwortung dass auch wir hier unsere
werte ernst nehmen wir sind solidarisch
mit der ukraine
weil ein volk über seine zukunft frei
entscheiden soll aber wir sind auch
solidarisch mit der ukraine weil sie
eine inspiration für uns selbst ist ich
danke
dass also der bundesfinanzminister
christian lipp der noch mal erklärt hat
wie jetzt die 100 milliarden euro
zusätzlich für die bundeswehr ausgegeben
werden können ab wann auch darüber
wollen wir hier im studio sprechen mit
bild live chef claus strunz was bleibt
jetzt nach dieser ersten runde antworten
auf die regierungserklärung von olaf
scholz bei dir hängen was ist das heute
für ein zeichen an entschlossenheit
möglicherweise raus vor allen dingen an
die ukraine also erstmal es ist eine
große stunde des parlamentarismus in
deutschland so muss eine demokratie
arbeiten und es ist wirklich traurig
dass man es erst so richtig merkt wenn
es fast schon zu spät ist aber gerade
noch rechtzeitig wir wollen jetzt auch
uns nicht in die apokalypse flüchten
zweitens der bundeskanzler hat eine
große rede gehalten die vielen in
erinnerung bleiben wird auf die wir noch
oft zurückblicken wird oppositionsführer
friedrich merz war kämpferisch aber im
grossen ganzen verpflichtet die
verliererin wenn man das etwas steil so
formulieren darf es für mich heute
annalena baerbock die eben 180 grad
wende der politik nicht mit sich selber
nicht mit den grünen verbunden hat
sondern als ist halt jetzt so
dargestellt hat da hätte ich mir mehr
ehrlichkeit gewünscht und die fand an
lindener jetzt ehrlich gesagt richtig
richtig gut dass er nochmal adressiert
hat was das für uns bedeutet dass was
wir beobachten noch aus 1000 2000
kilometer entfernung aber eben schon
verdammt nah ist eine bedrohung für uns
alle das hat er als einziger explizit
adressiert und er hat dann gesagt dass
er sich freut dass wir oder dass er
jetzt davon ausgeht dass wir die werte
endlich leben über die man immer nur
redet und eigentlich möchte man ihm
zurufen und diese werte verteidigt über
die wir immerhin leben und verteidigt
und dafür dazu gehört all das was jetzt
auf den weg gebracht worden ist heute
also viele große momente und ein kleiner
um annalena baerbock claus strunz bild
live chef vielen herzlichen dank